yeah i'm going on castings right now um
so far i'm booked for like catherine
malandrino and
heather i like made me cry paris why
why now why tell this story and release
all this information
now it actually was not supposed to be
the original premise of this film
i wanted to show the world the business
woman i am and the empire i built
and that ended up coming out naturally
because i
felt so comfortable with the director
you know
the one of the things that's interesting
about this is you admit to the world
that you were playing a character and
you know folks like us who have seen you
in
regular life seeing you walking around
seeing you just being paris we've seen
that person before but other people had
no idea
so what do you think the reaction will
be like in what was it like playing this
character
i think people are definitely going to
be very surprised when they see this
film and
see sides to me that they've never seen
before
i know that people who know me know me
but even the people who do know me don't
even know some of the things that i've
talked about in this film
so it's going to be very surprising and
shocking to people
um and then i think also it's gonna have
people understand me a lot more and
why i built this character to protect
myself
were you afraid to release it just to
let people in
and let them know this part of your life
yes it was something that i never wanted
to ever discuss
ever when i got out of there i made a
promise to myself that i would never
think about it
or talk about it with anyone ever
so to now have the whole world about to
see this in a couple of
days is just very nerve-wracking
your hustle and your grind is second to
none um
at what point at what point because it
seemed like
you really want to at some point just
slow down
and be paris or star
you just want to you just want to slow
everything down is that ever going to
happen
well you know during this pandemic it's
actually been the first time i've been
forced to slow down
and to not travel because usually i'm on
a plane
250 days a year i'm working non-stop and
this is the first time where i've
actually had to
pause and really reflect on my life and
what matters and i'm in the most
incredible relationship i'm
so happy and i'm just ready for the next
phase of my
life so uh i'm definitely going to still
do my business but i do want to slow
down in
the traveling and just working 24 7
because i have more important things i'm
focusing on
does this mean next phase in your life
like maybe marriage and children and
those kinds of things because
you have been so focused on business
that those things have fallen aside and
you've also
you admit in this documentary you have
struggled with
relationships and been in some really
bad ones
yes i was never really open to a
relationship
because i wasn't ready to open my heart
just because of what i had been through
so i never
let anyone fully in until now and
now i am just so excited for that next
step and
to get married and have babies and
just finally be hap as happy as i always
wished
what does it take for a man to be in
your life 24
7 i mean how hard is that for some dude
to come in and i mean you're a force of
nature
well he's my perfect match he really is
just
so incredible so supportive loyal kind
brilliant and i look up to him so much
he's always giving me business advice
and
is just so just caring and romantic and
we just have the best time together so
even though this pandemic has been very
hard i try to see the silver lining
and we have been together 24 7 and it's
just been
incredible damn so you're really in like
this is it you're in love
love like this is you right i am
so deeply in love it's like i've never
ever truly felt like this it's it's
mind-blowing
wow something happened to my childhood
that i've never talked about with anyone
i just heard screaming bloody murder
but i couldn't tell you guys because
every time i tried i would get punished
by them
i still have nightmares about it there's
one thing that you talked about is you
talked about
the school messed you up so much that
you couldn't feel anything that you
didn't even
even something like the sex tape it
didn't matter to you because you were
just
numb how bad was it there and where were
you at mentally when those kinds of
things were happening
i well dur that tape was one of the most
painful
experiences i've ever been through in my
life um and i would never have put
myself
in that position or met a man like that
if i had not
went through what i went through because
at these places being abused
it makes it almost seem like it's normal
and um i was just i was so numb i was so
lost and i
just met the worst type of person you
could ever meet
you know what's interesting about that
is if that had happened today
in this day and age it would have been a
very different story and he would have
been looked at as a predator
instead of you know this guy like holy
because you took
a lot of heat and abuse because of that
didn't you
i did and if that happened today it
would
be a completely different story
um so it's terrible that i had to deal
with that but at least now
women are going to be getting i don't
know
the respect that they deserve and when
something happens to them they're a
victim
it's not their fault so
yeah i'm happy things are changing at
least for others
paris what is new paris going to be like
like now that the
look the game's uh you know like the
game's over
the old paris is gone what's the new
paris going to be like and what are
people going to get from you now
they're going to get who i really am and
i want to use my platform to raise
awareness for causes that i care about
one of those is breaking code silence
where survivors are coming forward of
stories because there are
still today thousands and thousands of
children in these places being abused
and
nobody knows about it and no one
believes them and
for me to speak and be brave there's so
many people i'm getting
outdoors of letters and videos and
people just sending me just
how grateful they are that i told my
story because they finally can tell
their story and they're finally speaking
to their
families again there's parents they're
pulling their children out of provo
canyon school and other schools like
this
so this is actually making a difference
so i'm just excited just to
use my platform for the greater good
paris i've been in a couple of those
scrums when the media just
loses its mind and you're in the middle
of like the madness of the media
that time that moment all those things
like when you go around
are you ready to leave that behind you
has are you
is have you kind of had enough of that
i'm just focused on the future
of course i'm going to continue my
businesses and brands i just released my
27th fragrance
and in the studio i have six singles
that are coming out
i'm writing my third book i'm doing my
own
cooking show that's coming out soon um
so i'm embarrassed how much is
how much is enough how much is enough
like what is the point
i'm always going to be a boss babe but
i'm also going to be a grown-up and i'll
be
a mom and wife you
okay really how long when are you ready
to be a mom because that also includes
slowing down
a little bit not in 2020 this year
is just the craziest year ever
so 2021 definitely
wow that's okay yeah i feel you pear
okay i i hear you and i feel you on that
you and nikki are so close and in this
in the documentary when she says
she was a naughty girl what does she
mean by what does she mean what's going
on with you
at the time i actually wasn't not
naughty at all just compared to nikki i
was
the only thing i would do was sneak out
at night
go to clubs and then ditch school that
was it
like i wasn't even partying i was dating
boys like
it was nothing like that all i cared was
to go out
dress up look cute and dance and that's
it
but my parents were so strict and i had
lived such a sheltered life before i
moved to new york
so they just were freaking out because
i've never like been to a party or went
on a date before i moved to new york
and by the way nikki also admits that
she she dimed on you a lot she told on
you a lot
i didn't know that so that that made me
a little upset
she's a little tattletail she was
listening to your phone calls
did you you had no idea did you she was
spying on me
what's the relationship between you two
like now what does she mean to you
everything she is my best friend there's
no one in the world who knows
me like she does and
i look up to her like she's a big sister
even though she's my little sister
because
she's just always been the more mature
one and we're just complete opposites
but she just tells it how it is and i i
don't really have
a lot of people like that in my life so
it's good to have someone around who
always tells me the truth paris you have
always been ahead of the curve
what's the next thing what's the next
thing look down the road open the
crystal ball
tell us what's coming up next
i think what's next especially just in
the whole influencer world i think
that the new influencer is the activist
and i'm seeing a lot of that right now
this new generation that really cares
about the planet
they care about making a difference and
really fighting for causes
and i find that to be just
so commendable and i really applaud them
and i'm impressed by it
and i don't know i just see this whole
shift right now
and it's very impressive how close were
you to coming up with the selfie
you made it popular but how close were
you to coming up with it
i invented the selfie
i was doing selfies back before there
was iphones like literally
with camcorders with disposable cameras
with anything so
i've been doing that forever paris what
is it that you know
that the rest of the world doesn't know
to understand
like these things that pop in pop
culture
i think i don't know i've just always
been ahead of my time
i'm an aquarius so i'm creative
i'm like a futuristic person
and i'm half alien
[Laughter]
can we show you we're going to show you
an old cl we're going to show you an e.t
clip we want to show you this right now
check this out are you going to be doing
anything
yeah i'm going on castings right now um
so far i'm booked for like catherine
malendrino and
heathera and pirro and uh waiting to
hear back from other people i'm just
going every day
any other projects um
well my cameo zoolander which is coming
out like the premiere is like
two weeks so that's gonna be cool how is
that working with ben
he's awesome i like him a lot yeah it's
funny enjoy tonight thank you
thank you
what do you think what would you tell
that girl what do you remember about
that girl
i like made me cry so sweet
um wow that that
i would tell that girl don't worry be
strong
you're gonna make it through anything
and
that was that was amazing to watch and i
look the same